мобільний по звуку дещиці
своїм
друзі всім добром вчора на ходинку у
нас не надавши до 2000 це означає
платформою мотиви піт ринку міністерства
святі наука україни і кожні виходить у
ефір ви знаю чому рядок і ми з відома
ми українці ми а також з давнім та дітям
це психологом і для того, щоб до пункту
namseng бригад та spoke to
адекватний масивний стан vc ситуації
сьогодні у нас уже місяць не відкриваючи вина
в Україні цьому ми підготували для вас з
кутового гостя з він лабаз лінчук в на і
клінічним психологом
спеціалістам чиндо психології хреста
роботі та країну ми також директора МТС
екологічна служби а йєльського
університету місяць
з ізраїлю алла причину валирою nh та
шинчинниці можна сказати вона сама
родом з харкова all і проїхала душа
давно таммуз ваші художнику я буду
просила ти сьогодні російську мою щоб
символу дорослими дьорга вольга добрий
вечір вам
ну по перше хочу сказати велике
дякую що відгукнулися на наше
пропозиція на наше прохання
приєднатися до роботи платформу це
для нас дуже цінно, бо в Україні
є свого роду така розхожа думка
про ізраїль як країну яка воює
практично всю свою історію та
безумовно в ізраїлі є величезний досвід
і в роботі з
психологічними травмами
роботі зі збройними силами тому у
нас дуже цінно саме ваша
практика ось
це так це правда у мене особисто теж є
в я які мігрували з України ось
нещодавно в ізраїлі теж багато цікавого
раніше бачив ці фотографії роботи
вашого залізного бані і мені здавалося
що це це звичайно дарма та он коли ти
сидиш ставили бачиш ось ці ось просто
литві, що летить
але зараз ми ось у Києві бачимо
приблизно те саме тільки на жаль
не із залізного бані з с-300 але як
кажуть в Україні моєму те що
власне давайте тоді почнемо напевно
з самого початку ви знаєте, що у нас ось
місяць собі твій на всі ми дуже дуже
емоційно це переживаємо хоч і по
різному але кожне емоційно хтось
знаходиться в тих регіонах України, де
нічого не відбувається хтось живе під
обстрілами фізично бореться за життя
тому ось з погляду психіки
людини що відбувається коли ти ось
опинився в умовах війни людина
який цього ніколи не був підготовлений
від річки психіка природно реагує
почали на те, що відбувається так, як би
людина переживає шокову та
травматичного реакцію більшості
випадків це шок варі акція в якійсь
момент вирівнюється людина починає
функціонувати
основне як те що основне
відбувається коли нору відбувається
кризова ситуація порушується принцип
безперервності що два принципи
безперервності життя принцип
безперервності існування що це
значить загалом і в цілому це означає завтра
буде те саме що я сьогодні тобто
у нас є якісь стандартні корчі
які ми розхожим думкам говоримо будинок
діти робота дім робота діти і так далі
коли відбувається кризова ситуація
більше війна і тим більше така важка
масштабний цей принцип порушується як
є те, що було вчора залізно не буде
сьогодні і завтра взагалі незрозуміло що
буде і на інше порушення принципу
безперервності наша психіка реагує
як вона реагує є три витрати вже
три три основні варіанти реакцій
перших які іноді на російську це не
дуже правильно переклав водиться бейбі
замри біжи замри правильно це
знаменита я б не перекладала бей
flight fight як убий я би це призвела до
Свою воюй біжи замри, бо на самому
справі сенс або в тому, щоб когось або
щось біт а тому що це активна
позиція що таке у червні це якщо я
щось
як би людину в процесі кризи
включаючи
механізм виживання, щоб вижити потрібно
отримати їжу питво мінімальний дах над
головою чи якесь більш-менш але як
мало можливе захищене місце
тому люди як люди з активної позиції
часто як би цього це воюють вони воюють
як би і шукають активно
як як з цим впорається біги та дитячі
шанси на отримання бажаного занадто
примарні та активна позиція не допомагає
другий варіант бібі і особливо якщо
віскі
високі тобто це якась скажемо так
внутрішні ваги якщо гра не варта свічок
та активна позиція чи допомагає ґрунт
бігти замри це третій варіант це
третя літера f англійською до втекти
і напасти неможливо наприклад якщо ви
опинилися на краю урвища і бігти так само
як і
і як воювати може бути 8 небезпечно павучі
завмерти і не кидатися стрімголов
видно виходу можна або впасти в
пропасти чи ще щось чи потрібно
сховатися тоді ви що завмерти наш
лимон нас як дітей завжди навчає все
Наші предки загалом це гра на
виживання
ще одна річ, яку не до важливо
підкреслити
попередній зустрічі з вами розповім
великий
поговорити про
посттравматичному стресовому
розладі
я скажу як би гумор це один із способів
виживати справлятися до птср треба ще
дожити що називається по-перше
посттравматичний розлад не
розвивається відразу для того, щоб
розлучилася і дай бог посттравматичне
розлад потрібно що було пост травку
тобто після травми тому я гордо
птср кого потрібно ще навіть і
розвивається але я не пам'ятаю точні цифри
можливих помилок і тут 10-15 відсотків
ситуації блакитна 15 відсотків любив
яких більш слабкі механізми виживання
слабші захисні механізми люди
дуже відрізняються один від одного психічному
розвитку хто як вони росли і які
патерни і в них усередині як би як
впоратися з цим тому як у коли
ми говоримо про кризову ситуацію навколо
посттравматичним стресом розлади
говорити рано і розвивається на
мінімальної кількості але не на
невеликій кількості відсотку випадків
тому більшість людей повертається
психіка штука гнучка люди повертається
місяць місяць свої україна воює і важкий
воює а люди як би я думаю що ті хто
зламалися не готова воювати набагато
менше ніж я готові які готові
воювати триматися до останнього це
називає цю мужність викликає глибоке
повага до людей постійно або скажемо так
час від часу воюючі нам це добре
зрозумілі та по-людськи професійно
ось тут якраз хотів вас
подякувати за комплімент тому що
ізраїлю якраз від ізраїльських громадян
цьому чути мені здається досить
гідно поваги ви як ніхто знаєте
що це і тут якраз я хотіла б вас
запитати з приводу цього місяця тому
що я наприклад спостерігаю як розвивається
моєї реакції від повного шоку я особисто не
вірю, що велика війна можлива
думав може бути якесь локальне
загострення там знову продовження
гібридної війни але так щоб ось прямий
як знаєте сорок першому до київ бомбили
нам оголосили що почалася війна як
старої радянської пісні слабко собі це
уявляв і моя психіка пройшла
трансформацію ось просто хвилеподібну та
зараз я особисто особисто я в якійсь
стадії прийняття напевно повного тобто
я розумію що відбуваюся відбувається мене
вже не дивують не якісь новини з
фронту скажемо так тобто якесь
певне насичення, але при цьому ми
отримуємо повідомлення від наших глядачів
регулярно про те, що у них і так
формуємо як запит і люди на
по-різному в різних емоційних станах
знаходиться у когось глибока депресія
людина не може взагалі нічого робити на
там я лежу цілий день все читаю новини
у когось неконтрольованої агресії хочу
піти вбивати росіян це може бути
навіть жінка наприклад із дворічним
дитиною у когось
[музика]
згодували за рахунок на чому чоловік часто
ось навіть не сумніваюся у
когось ще якісь реакції тобто
чи є ці реакції в принципі
нормальними тобто від повного розуміння
як би усвідомлення та прийняття нормальної
життя довго таких ось як би украй
до речі за місяць
через basic як би я говорила
психіка пластичні вона пристосовується
практично до всього
пристосуватися людина може практично
до всього і в якийсь момент одягнув він
починає шукати те, що говорю про принцип
безперервності тобто коли починається
війна перший тиждень люди не були
перебували в шоці тому що по-перше
ніхто не чекав все-таки що це
відбудеться залишити політику за дужками
але як би психологічної я думаю ніхто
не очікував як би я думаю на Україні поза
україни будь-яка реакція на стрес
первинна вона легітимне нормально є
таке поняття нормальний ряд ненормально
обставини
тобто ситуація ненормальна як були
хто загалом не чекав війни війна це не те
щоб
середньостатистична прийнятна ситуація
хоча у
ізраїлю життя в ізраїлі вані і навчила
назад але тим не менш як банальний але
і але в будь-якій ненормальній ситуації в
якийсь момент у нас є нормальна
реакція перша реакція будь-яка нормальна
немає жодних нормальних реакцій це не зовсім
депресія чи агресія у чистому вигляді
тому що дуже важливо розрізняти
депресивну агресивну реакцію
як явище як реакцію на якесь складне
події
депресію як психічне захворювання
коханцем будь-яка реакція цілком час
депресивна реакція це
спроба психіки дати відпочити самій
собі полежати почитати а потім у
якийсь момент стати дуже рідко
особливо люди, у яких є діти
жінки
тут немає різниці яких є діти
лежатимуть постійно їсти якісь як
мінімальна кількість у якійсь
процес людей які впаде у тяжку
депресію але більшість аматор до
відпочити до дадуть психіки відпочити і
стану таких ситуаціях дуже важливо
прислухатися до себе те саме, що й
агресивна реакція
рідко агресивної реакції йдуть на
близьких людей тобто ми звичайно можемо
більш дратівливі і менш терпіти
дитячі витівки так далі це
природно але важкі веслувати ми рідко
виявляємо до близьких людей
агресивні бажання більш ніж нормально
якщо хтось приїхав кидати на мене богу
не його дуже хочеться якимось якимось
або ви бачили щось з ним
зробити чи важливо хто цей кидає
пам'ятаю я хочу, щоб ти перестав
припинилося як це можна припинити
тільки агресивно тобто тим, як би
знову ж таки висловлювання агресії
вона різне питання не в тому чи говорю
агресивно чи хочу зробити
агресивна дія питання в тому, що я
роблю насправді що називається
реалізуючи свої агресивні наміри
якщо реалізує як більшість людей як
швидше це немає дати вони свої
агресивні
реалізує тому що все-таки розумію
що по-перше це неефективна в
друге є чим зайнятися крім цього ви
зустрінете
це небезпечно
літаком слабо не побоюсь
навіть залізним куполом
загалом будь-які реакції є нормальним
нормальними для людської психіки так
і тому не зможе
я не дуже люблю шкала нормально не
нормально тому, що в неї є якийсь
елемент засуджувати засудженням нормально
мабуть добре ненормальний мабуть не
дуже добре а ось
природні практично будь-яка реакція
кризової ситуації природно у тяжкій
ситуації немає неприродних реакцій та
нового більш природна реакція це
швидше тривалість тобто якщо
людина лежить депресії на місяць то це
звичайно нікуди вже не годиться і треба що
то робити щоб цього не відбувалося але
кого ж вуличного вивести людину з
цій ситуації але якщо як кілька днів
щоб мобілізувати психіку давенда вже
приходимо криза ситуація дуже різних
обставинах є а який приходить
ослаблені за якимись своїми є люди
які не дай боже поховали довоєнний
своїх близьких або розлучилися, а сварилися
щось сталося тут не ми приходимо
дуже різний при дуже різних
обставинах ось я хотів би з вами
якраз про останні обставини
поговорити у нас жаль сьогодні з
міста в Україні які той маріуполь
родзинки ельфів та інші яке ну
практично цілодобово знаходяться під
обстрілами і дуже жорстокими
обстрілами та люди там реально поставлені
на межу виживання без води без благ
цивілізації банальних ось таким людям
які знаходяться не просто у стресовому
ситуації про супер це стресовий і
причому тривалий час це триває
кілька тижнів як і мені як вам
взагалі зберегти потенціал напевно бути
собою що там не розгубити
психічне своє здоров'я по-перше
дуже важливо їсти таке на івриті поняття
і зробити на івриті спробую чітко
прийти на те є дбайливе ставлення
напевно правильніше перевести лобі
особисті відношення до себе зазвичай нас як
б у радянській та пострадянській
просторі
дозволю собі це термін вчили бути
активні і не шкодувати не шкодувати себе
живота свого та всього іншого свого
так далі західний підхід та не тільки
західна хата певною мірою східна
каже все до смерті серце дбайливо
адже себе треба треба бабайка собі потрібно
прислухатися абсолютно необов'язково
рватися рвати себе на шматочки щоб
впоратися з такими ситуаціями по-перше
психіка пристосуватися наче в якійсь
момент навіть якщо ну як би знову я б
назвала воду та їжу благами цивілізації я
би назвав це викликало необхідність
без води людина може прожити я вже не
пам'ятаю скільки годин образи я вже не пам'ятаю
скільки доби але дуже небагато тому
це не допомагає, а необхідність такої
ситуації в принципі людина включає
дуже те, що ми називаємо комп'ютери
стоїть мод
я не знаю як перекласти це російською
англійська
збережеться грубо кажучи коли коли
видалася коли операційна система якщо
ми подивимося
працювати на мінімумі як би на мінімум
ресурсів тобто
зазвичай психіка включає в якийсь
момент сайт мод і важливо себе підтримати
себе як пошкодувати себе приголубити себе
не робити щось скажемо так супер і
зарамаг виходить по-перше будь-який
вчинок, що виходять з рамок, він вимагає
величезної кількості енергії а що таке
selfmade це коли ми у собі олега ви
зберегли довгомір для потрібно скажемо так
нам потрібно функціонувати на мінімум та
енергії набагато більша внутрішня
психічне емоційні та когнітивні
енергії будь-якої енергії дуже багато
часу тому потрібно до себе ставитись
обидва дуже важливо ставитися дбайливо і не
робити різких рухів якщо у них немає
необхідності тобто функціонувати на
мінімум та психологічних ресурсів
зберігаючи їх та намагаючись бути вам спілкуватися
з людьми які скажемо так поряд близькі
коли ми змінюємось
інформація міняємося одні емоції коли
натисли коли ми жалкуємо коли ми
співчуваємо треба відчувати величезний
ресурс як би ми тварини стадної ми всі
вийшли зі стада до людей-людей як би і
або стадо стоїть зовсім неважливо
швидше 100 ставити як і в нас
звичка яка перетворилася на
МіжособистіснІ стосунки
спілкування для нас необхідний ресурс
тому з лего є можливість
допомагати спілкуватися потихеньку полігоні
чпу
не розриваючи себе шматочки теж може бути
прийнято якщо людина зіткнулася в цих
умовах із втратою і таких людей теж
дуже багато причому це може бути як
втрата і близької людини рідної так і
напевно майна і чого завгодно
несправедливістю якоїсь такої вселенської
яка тимчасова
.
як би
сперечатися з цим безглуздо
це нам щодня цивілізація знову і
знову доводить
тому як би на люди як правило
стресової ситуації дуже рідко думають про
справедливості світу це роздуми з
області коли у нас є що поїсти
щоб пити у нас тепло над головою 2 1 2
частина якого не здається менш скажемо
так важливо і але менш важливе це майно
найефективніший спосіб знову-таки
сказати тобі дякую що взяв грошима
він складно те більшому почуття тим
важче щось говорити я вже не кажу про
будиночок у вас будинок може бути маленький там
може бути чи не бути золота та
діамантів на це все одно ми будинок я
будівництво кожна цегла і це дуже
важко сказати не те щоб я пропоную
що те, що легко зробити але це важливо
як би ніби Господь врятував тебе що
взяла сережками а якщо господи що
називається зробили грошима, а людина
втрачає близьку людину це сама
складна ситуація особливо вона складна
тому що в ситуації війни ми маємо
справу з передчасною та
передчасної та поза
сказати як би не чекаємо
[музика]
втрати як би людини молодої
і
людина вмирає
скажемо так неприродно
він смерті spear близького це один
з найбільших та найважчого місто
дуже важливо розуміти, що ця подія
яке не могло це
це переживання особливо якщо батьки
втрачаєте тінь
досить часто навіть коли втрачає в
загалом подружжя хоча я не знаю і не дуже
можу порівнювати горе але проте
б у титу та подія яка неможлива
пережити 1 момент тобто на те щоб
скажемо так повірити, що це сталося
прийняти перестати і
перебудувати не перестати та перебудувати
життя з урахуванням втрата потрібен час є
скажімо так на наукові слідуючи рік 6
кілька етапів горя але я хочу
поговорити про первинні реакції тому
що зараз хіба що важливо допомогти тренчу
це впоратися з первинним з тим, що
сталося саме зіткнення з фактом
кінцівки життя близького близького дуже
дуже складно прийняти це найскладніше
один будинок не одні діаманти жодна
біла
не встоїть поряд з тим
щоб
викликає сам одні з найсильніших
відчуттів з якими нам людям важче
впораються безпорадності та безсилля
тобто це є три речі з яким на
людської психіки найважче
впоратися
безпорадність безсилля та невідомість
до ситуації втрата близької людини поза
часу у мене часу як би раніше
часу
природного це як би невідомості до
жаль вже немає, але безпорадності і
безсилля є при цьому відомо що для
того, щоб будувати плани і не жити одним
днем людині важливо відчувати свою
здатність контролювати якимось
чином впливати на ситуацію, а в ситуації
коли йде близька людина особливо
якщо він йде раптова і поза часом
це можливості немає тобто на жаль
представлене при зіткненні зі
смертю близької людини ці переконання
повинні бути як ці переконання що ми
можемо впливати на ситуацію вони
піддаються
тобто коли ми втрачаємо близько вас
розуміння на що ми не впливаємо на всякому
випадку як допомогли наш канал дуже мало
тобто життя перестає бути
передбачуваний навіть коли є війна в
загалом у якийсь момент життя стає
присудкам це ненормальна ситуація ось
як ми його собі сказали ну ось ви знаєте
що далі буде
природна ситуація але приблизно
уявляю і що треба робити у ситуації
припустимо бомбардування я пам'ятаю що перші дні
якби виворітною стороною втрати як би
більшість населення України не знала
що робити при бомбардуванні або це сама
пам'ятаю що одного з перших днів я слухаю
якийсь передачу на та на івриті коли
їхала на роботу машині та вигляду ще дуже
відома ведуча спитала а як би вони
встигають давида бомбосховища я як би
сумно і тяжко знову і які
бомбосховищ
які захищені кімнати в ізраїлі у бою
більшості будівель останніх років є
одна броньована кімната практично в
будь-якому будинку і в нас допустимо живим старим
будинку але у мене бомбосховища
бомбосховища захищена
20 метрів від сходів моєї квартири як
б це до новини тобто мені страшно було
сумно і ситуація інша в але тим не менш
менш я пам'ятаю, що я інструктував свою
близьку подругу у харкові відкрилася
сайту
ізраїльська служби тилу спробувала
послати її ролик російською не змогла
тому що сайт був закритий
міжнародну
використання сили та проінструктував а
стій під вовками далеко від атак вона ще
чогось і в якийсь момент ми
починаємо але коли у гине якщо
повернутися вмирає гине раптово
близька людина хоча ми уявляємо що
під час але сам факт він життя поділяється на
до і після
і це після вже ніколи не буде тим
яким воно було так якби після війни
якщо ніхто з близьких не загинув, є шанс
відновити якийсь більш менш
рівновага якщо загинув хтось близький це
після вже ніколи не повернеться та й тоді
дуже важлива людина допомогти виправити
це перейняти далі вже буде якісь
підуть процес але перший час
дуже важливо з ким щось говоріть щоб
хтось був поруч
навколишні музика дуже важливо щоб був
хтось близький або хоча б хтось поруч
і зовсім неважливо навіть не зовсім
неважливо чан зазвичай не важливо що він
каже головне щоб хтось живий
каталог якому ця людина не
байдужий був присутній за його життя
приблизно так зрозуміло
сподіваюся більшості або всім нашим з
нашим глядачам не знадобиться все-таки
ця інформація дана але ми нічого не
можемо звичайно тут гарантувати
але я абсолютно точно знаю що ми
жаль можемо гарантувати сьогодні
прийшла статистика щоб проведено опитування та
майже 50 відсотків українців
втратили роботу чи перебувають відчуття
простою тобто оплата там мінімальних
якихось
грошових коштів і якщо знаєте як
спочатку нам здавалося що можливо там
це вільно швидко закінчиться там тиждень
або ще якось зараз ми розуміємо що
ні швидко не вийде і з цим люди
починають перебувати в такому стані
постійно тривожності за своє майбутнє та
банально за що мені їстиме
докупити там
ось як ось у цьому стані краще
діяти для того, щоб
Основний
принцип я подумаю про це завтра
як би те, що ми не можемо вирішити сьогодні
ми відкладаємо на подумати на завтра
знову таки скажемо так йде ліворуч розріз
з якимось постулатом якого всякому
випадку
вчили мене коли я росла те, що можна не
відкладай на завтра те, що можна
зробити сьогодні але я як би я б
продовжив це не думаючи про те, що
неможливо зробити сьогодні сьогодні
подумаю про те, коли це можна буде сюди
сяде їсти принципи скарлетт о'хара я
подумала в цьому завтра тобто якщо
неможливість чимось впоратися сьогодні
про це як би ну максимально бажано
не думати не завжди це можливо люди
відрізняються рівнем тривожності від не
відрізняються типом реакції на події
проте ще один принцип який
скажемо так сприятливо
впливає на психіку це принцип маленьких
кроків отримали планувати далекі
майбутнє коли руйнується світ планувати
далекі майбутнє просто піщаного ніхто
не знає куди коли вливати ось скінчиться
війна і тоді нехай закінчиться війна у нас
буде ще роки це все відновлювати
якщо ви десятиліття як будемо
відновлювати себе ми
відновлювати міста ми будемо
встановлювати все що завгодно починаючи від
будинків та закінчуючи самими собою ми будемо
будувати що називається тому принцип
маленьких кроків дуже важливо озирнутися
і зрозуміти що я можу зробити сьогодні і на
що я можу вплинути сьогодні
більшість біженців слава тобі господи
отримує якусь допомогу тобто робота
в принципі такої ситуації через те, що
все-таки щастя що існує
благодійність і людина не
знаходиться у військовій зоні де є
постійна та
конкретна загроза життю як правило у
його є де спати у нього є що є
це звичайно не рябчики і не гра яка
була раніше але проте є як
право є психологічна допомога
хоча б на мінімальну та допомогу дітьми
є медична допомога це ж величезна
якщо порівняти це з тим, що було в
маріуполі і як ви скажемо так і після
того як буде слав які змогли
втекти і змогли вижити комп це небо і
земля
я може горіти дещо якісну
річ але коли я порівнюю ці речі
різні слава богу що встиг такий араб
будь їм потрібно буде думати коли
підійде час
коли цьому буде час треба себе
поберегти і якщо їй що є де спати
чим нагодувати дітей та вилікувати якісь
хвороби які якісь речі які
необхідно лікувати прямо зараз
вже дуже багато і тому все інше
покроково
принципу пожалій себе з ми беремо цей
фокус уваги, які раніше у нас був
десь далеко і на глобальному саджаємо його
до 10 то наближаємо до того що ми
можемо вплинути знову-таки тому, що в
кризову ситуацію, а країна військових наша
можливість на щось вплинути на
мінімально знову-таки згадуємо що нам
найважливіше нам з чим складніше сила
впоратися з безсиллям з невідомістю
і
третє у мене вилетіло з голови, але я
говорила щойно
краще звужує фокус зору на те, що ми
можемо вплинути це що важливо
зараз де спати не замерзнути збільшити
те, що потрібно вилити і що поїсти чим
зайняти дітей та якимось чином
мінімально ну побалувати не сказав би
як би пошкодувати себе і дбайливо якщо
ненавидь такий принцип це і
принципі з тори якщо я так собі не
чи амелі на мілини з лінія тому
дуже важливо зайнятися собою і дати
собі
поблажки тому що це формує нашу
здатність справлятися набагато довше і
набагато ефективніше з більш дальні про
наслідками, як коли вони з'являться
так нелегко це усвідомити я просто
чому це питання шукає вже сформулювало
у мене є прямий мій дуже хороший
знайомий які слава богу сім'ю їхав
виміряю так недавно і
у нього напевно така первинна
адаптація до того що він поїхав був навколо
тижня а зараз він ось говорити про просто
встала бонусна більше нічого немає мене
був там бізнес будинком не просто нічого
ні абсолютно він ну як би там не вчора
народився до життя це будував залишився
Чи схеми каже ось це ось відчуття
порожнечі це просто жах якийсь та у
нього є якісь запаси є що
їсть але можуть купити фокус, яким ми
говоримо з вами він поки що тримає там
де він тримав лікар насправді втрати
я того чого 100 про все життя це теж
величезні втрати та бізнес з якоюсь
ступеня особливо працюючий бізнес це
як ще одна дитина як би
війну чи за таких обставин люди
дуже часто фокусується на тому вчені
що вони втратили мені здається дуже важливо
паралельно спробуємо постаратися
себе сфокусуватися на тому, що залишилося
залишилося життя
залишилося здібності якщо один раз
побудував успішний бізнес та шанс що
побудує і ще раз ніби я розумію що
мені легко говорити про це в умовно
кажучи людині, яка втратила це
набагато важче я боронь господь не маю
через це все легко це звичайно все
важко але дуже важливо потрапити і роздай і
утворюється величезна порожнеча чає був за
не цілий день займався бізнесом діти
робота дружина і тут маса славно умовно
кажучи вільного часу, який ти
навіть якщо дуже хочеш не може
витратити на те, що ти любиш це теж в
якоюсь мірою втрата але порожнеча
хороша тим, що в якийсь момент і можна
заповнити якщо раніше ваш друг міг
побудувати з нас я більше, ніж впевнена
що займе звичайно час цього
відновлювати дуже довго та не легко
але бізнес побудувати
один раз побудував значить здатність
є це дуже терміново
наше відео обов'язково якщо не дивиться з
не думаю передайте другу один раз
побудую більш ніж його це тяжко це
дуже складно та важко
один раз зробити і більш ніж впевнена
буде можливо також як і будинок також як
і стіни робота головне щоб люди
близькі вижили
життя звичайно все
Ольга у нас закінчується час і я
хотів би тому як такий
останнього моменту ми зазвичай закінчуємо
на позитиві ось це побажання ваші що
українці
сьогодні сьогодні знаходиться тут
по-перше перемоги
по друге сил
витримку я не даю, бо витримка
українців знімаю капелюх
мирного неба над головою та швидкого
відновлення і звичайно рамоса люди я
хотів би під кінець якщо можна пару слів
сказати я беру участь досить великому
проект психологічної допомоги
українським жителем та українським
психологом нас працює нас я частина
тільки мала частина цього проекту
працює 200 з чимось
волонтерів, які психотерапевтів
ізраїльських я б хотів вам потім виставити
посилання є навіть сайт на допомагає
програмісти нам допомагає люди логістики
тому що психологи та психотерапевти
логістику саму ніколи не підніму, а ось
я б хотіла потім вам надіслати ось посилання
куди можна звернутись і наші фахівці
передзвонюють і
і або вайди рами ллється фон з якимсь
чим люди просять передзвонити але
передзвонюємо і намагаємося допомогти здалеку
психологічними здається важливо щоб
українські жителі це знали, наскільки ми
здатні ми допоможемо до великого вам
дякую якраз друзям і так дізналися про
діяльності оргію колегам ресурс
це форма заповнення гугл форму яка
причому ми дотримуємося секретності скажемо
так не всі знають всі дамі тобто
людина що пишуть вони повинні
з'явитися прізвище і навіть дані
конкретніше чому він звертається на
зберігаємо наскільки це можливо
секретно
так ми тоді публікуємо ще раз посилання під
цим відео та своїх
ольга ну я хотів би вам сказати величезне
дякую ще раз за те, що погодилися і
сподіваюся це не останній наш ефір тому
що тому що це дуже важливо я
тобі бажаю в якийсь момент стати
безробітні але ви на моєму житті навряд чи
не потрібно
мого життя на жаль моя спеціальність
буде ніч
мирного неба дякую
дякую дому всього доброго і дякую
всього найкращого
друзі ідучи ще був з на ми сьогодні я
двічі платформою масивного біт ринку
міністерство святі науках а владно
зустрину масі завтра exim норми вночі
до завтра